I think you can see how to write
the algorithm at this point, but
just to be complete,
let me formalize it.
First, my algorithm maintains two
copies of the rank and next buffers.
You need two copies because the
interfaces to update ranks subroutines,
always wrote their outputs
to a separate copy.
Remember that the extra copies
ensure that rights can happen
in parallels safely.
The algorithm itself basically just
does a sequence of sealing of log m
update and jump steps.
You can see the two copies here.
After we do the simultaneous update and
jump steps, we do a swap.
There's one last step you need,
which is to return either R1 or
R2 depending on which was
the last copy updated.